[Music]
do you want me to update you on MILF
Manor because I watched episode two
because I'm doing like a part two video
no I [__] I I actually want to dive
into this one I think but I want to tell
you
I want to tell you I want to tell you
about episode two
and then you can pick up and watch it
all right all right go ahead go ahead go
ahead let it rip okay so we went through
the first episode right right
no we did you remember what happened you
remember disco Mommy
yeah okay and then she tries to bring
the guy back and so like
in my mind I'm like how could it get
much worse than that right
and
in episode do not tell me the dad gets
on the show no no he doesn't they do
this challenge where they all write
their like deepest darkest like sexual
secret basically
and okay then they all go up on a wall
and one by one they all have to walk up
to the wall and guess which one is their
mom or their son's secret oh fun and
they're all sexual so it's like really
[__] uncomfortable watching these
Suns walk up to the board and be like uh
has my mom had a foursome before
oh my mom would [__] somebody in an
elevator probably that that'd be a hurt
thing to do
and so they basically the way that they
win the game is by stumping the other
person so if they guess wrong then they
win
so it encourages them to write a really
dark secret that they wouldn't
necessarily pin on their mom or their
son right of course so one of the
secrets is I [__] my son's best friend
so they all go one by one and they all
kind of see that one they're like holy
[__] that is like all the rest are kind
of funny and now it's like that one's
real like that's
that's [__] up right that's like a
line that you should never cross you
know
out of all the [__] up [__] on this
show like that is [__] crazy
especially if the sun doesn't know yet
right
so you're kind of left like wondering
like who's who whose was that and then
they all sit in a room together and
they're drinking and they're like having
fun going around the room figuring out
if they were right or wrong right and it
gets to
so young who's like this Asian mother
and she
is like you know he it goes to his
secret his secret was that he got pink
eye eating ass so they're laughing about
it and he was like you know when the way
you eat ass like sometimes you know it's
whatever and they're all laughing hahaha
and he's like okay Mom what's yours
and she's like kind of choked up a
little bit she doesn't really want to
say it right so you can feel it you're
like oh it's the one
no and you're about to see this kid's
World get rocked you know
and she looks him right in the eye and
she's like mine was I [__] your best
friend okay like
and he's like
and you can just see like his face just
drops and he's just
like processing every emotion you could
possibly have
in that moment you know what I mean
like it's like who
who was it
you know who which one of my friends was
and then
and then right after there's like this
shot of him like talking into an iPhone
and he's like yeah I mean I just like
wasn't expecting this and I don't really
know how to
how to feel about it it's so real man
like
and like a really [__] up thing for
the producer to do obviously to be like
obviously to be like all right I know
there's traumatic things happen to you
why don't you go like rehash at all
relive it into the into the iPhone so we
have that shot too and then it just cuts
to him later and he's like drunk as [__]
naked in the pool like not making sense
clearly just drank himself into like a
stupor so he didn't remember any of that
and he's like talking to the DPS like
he's like so drunk he like forgets that
he's on a show the whole thing is so
[__] dark
he just hammered naked in the pool
yeah I remember yeah that's exactly what
it is like man some people man they
can't they don't understand the world
that I'm come from you would never be
able to handle it in my world and it's
like dude this is so sad and then it
cuts to the mom her talking headshot and
she's just crying and she's like this
happens right stuff like this kind of
happens
right crying crying on FaceTime with his
best friend
he's like it's okay baby it's okay baby
you just start slapping his dick on his
phone screen
dude
I'm sorry
it's all good it's all good I'll play
some war zone with him I'll talk on down
oh my god dude
just starts fathering him oh that's so
grim
yo dude are you texting yo how's it feel
that I'm your dad now
[Music]
did you know that no it doesn't look
like I knew that this is something I
never saw coming on I did not expect
this at all
I thought I knew my mom really well
I don't know what to think about it look
look yeah we're all in shock
he's like trying to save face you can
tell he's like you're trying to say face
in front of the camera yeah dude we're
all shocked right like you guys are
shocked too like you know
dude that's like that'd be like if a
comic was roasting someone in the crowd
and they're like hey man I [__] your
girlfriend yeah
she's all of our girlfriend now right yo
shout out to my wiener cousin yeah
wiener cousin
cousin yeah wait keep playing it because
there's a funny quote here I think about
it dude never
even disco mommy doesn't approve I know
I mean you're not gonna get it okay so
say it so I put that down because I
thought you're not gonna get it you over
here
look right here smash him up
[Laughter]
you see the way you said that oh yeah
my friends you said are we done and then
yeah and then like The Tick Tock kid's
like man that's the most Savage thing
yet
Savage
it's like dude I mean yeah that's like
literally Savage foreign
you know what I mean holy [__] dude
that's wild
yeah I mean this is truly the most
like
jaw-dropping insane show I've ever seen
and they're just ruining families it's
crazy
yeah [__] your friend's mom it's a
joke but
actually doing that is so wild
yeah I mean it but it's
just as much on the mom though more yeah
yeah no it's it's you know it's a two to
tango thing but I just mean
just conceptually if like you're like a
young dude in like your 20s or some [__]
and your friend's mom says hey
I want it and for you to be like all
right yeah this is just crazy it really
is
dang